so hopefully my talk will be worth you
missing a bit at lunch
hopefully my jokes
it will be funny enough so please make
sure your laugh so today I'm gonna talk
about JavaScript fatigue which is you
know the feeling you get with so many
packages with so many choices you have
to make so I've been maintaining charge
a s and synergize for quite a long time
now and well I think that actually this
is not a problem and today I'll tell you
why and while this talk comes from a
blog post I've written a while ago which
got to the first place in hockey news
and it was very controversial so but
yeah I do use it spaces instead of tabs
but this know what I'm going to talk
about today so I'm going to talk about
today is a subject that people don't
teach you in college and you know please
don't get me wrong I think college is
great I just think it likes a very
important subject which is called
realities of Industry 101 and the first
truth here is that software sauce
business problems somos software they're
like it doesn't have any great technical
requirements it doesn't need complex
infrastructure or doesn't have any
rigorous performance constraints and
that's because you're not page write
code you page solve problems right so
actually the less the last code you
write the better and that's because
technology's not a go so using heaps of
programming languages is not a go
using the latest frameworks is not a go
and I would even say that writing
beautiful code and Brooke free software
is not a go because the only thing that
matters is schools versus revenue so the
more you can increase your revenue and
decrease of course the better so we
don't actually avoid biting bugs because
we like correctness right we don't write
bugs because our clients or customers
don't like bugs and we also don't write
beautiful code just because we value
beautiful code we write beautiful code
because it makes us more productive in
the long run and that's good for
business so all these things you know
like launching rockets self-driving cars
robots AI well that doesn't just exist
because Elon Musk thinks it's very cool
it exists because people have economical
economic interests behind it and maybe I
should not even call the section
realities of us
maybe I should call it realities of
capitalism 101 and well if coding is not
the most important aspect of software
well then maybe we should start paying
more attention to other aspects such as
design so in this study Bowen has made
in 75 so he said a bunch of software and
he found out that 36% of errors came
from coding lost 64 percent came from
design and the NASA Apollo project
itself 73 percent of all errors were
design errors and that's because right
without requirements or design
programming is just the art of adding
bugs to an empty text file so there's
nothing worse than writing code that
shouldn't have been written at all and
if you remember that cost versus revenue
it's what matters you put even more
importance in design because good design
adds value faster then it adds goes and
all these things you know like view
react we're back like all these tools
Babel
they don't just exist because someone
thinks it's cool tried them they exist
because they need to solve a problem so
you must understand which problem you're
trying to solve before adopt a
technology you know don't just adopt it
because everyone's using it just because
it's cool because Jake a switching
happens when people use tools they don't
need to solve problems they don't have
and most of the times they do that in
the name of premature optimization which
according to done enough is the root of
all evil so why would you add a
necessary complex is very soft where if
you don't need that to solve a problem
right or go with solve problems not to
write code and if you're doing that in
their premature optimization just adding
a necessary complexity and the very
purpose of software engineering is to
control complexity not to created
especially because the greatest
performance of improvement of all is
when a system goes from not working -
working if it doesn't work doesn't
matter how fast it doesn't work so I
think that if we approached things like
we're doing TDD we would solve a lot of
problems when I mean - DDI like when I
say TDD I don't just mean writing tasks
before writing code I'm saying that we
should find
problems before trying to solve them and
you know TDD is not about test I even
wrote about this I think two weeks ago
and TDD is about taking gradual steps
towards a solution and if we do that we
will see that we will reduce the scope
of the decisions we gotta make and
therefore we'll have less options so it
becomes easier to make a choice and this
also decreases something we call and
allows this parallel is this and you
know you all know what this is this is
what happens when you open Netflix and
you're trying to choose what you're
gonna watch right so you have so many
options you get overwhelmed by them and
it makes it makes it harder to actually
make a choice because more choices mean
last satisfaction and as Barry Schwartz
says in his book the paradox of choice
as the number of options increase the
course in time and effort of gathering
the information needed to make a good
choice also increase and we pay for
those choices with willpower and
willpower is limited or willpower is
just like a muster so in this study we
can see the in like how many federal
decisions you just give according to the
time of the day so as you can see as
they starts they have about 65% of
verbal decisions and then when it starts
approaching their lunch break that that
number starts decreasing but when they
come back it goes all the way back up to
65% and the same thing happens when
they're about to go for coffee in the
middle of the afternoon
so with this we learn two things first
is that our willpower is limited
it's just like muscle and the second
thing is that if you ever commit a crime
make sure you're the first work first
one to go to court that day this will
greatly increase your chances of being
innocent so maybe we might not even be
jobs good for Chi
maybe we're just decision fatigue
because we're making choices the wrong
way but well what about jobs how did we
come to this place so I think first I
should show you a bunch of impressive
numbers to show how serious this is
so this is the growth of NPM in
comparison to other like package repost
package
management systems and every time I give
this talk yes that's me with the wizard
hat this number increases right now we
don't even have we have 700 more than
700 thousand packages on NPM that's an
average of 592 packages a day and that
growth rate is bigger than lots of
cities the NPM registry traffic has
grown 1,000 times in less five years
this is huge
but how did that happen well that
happened because the JavaScript
ecosystem has like very so we had many
problems in the JavaScript system we
needed to so so all these tools as I've
explained the existence of problems
transpires for transpilers for example
like Babel they exist to solve the the
problem that we have to write latest
generation code and make it work in
different platforms right we need to do
things such as writing gsx right so we
need these things because they help us
experimental features helping with help
us with platform compatibility and all
that module bundlers well you might
remember the time when we had to add
multiple script tags for HTML files and
that caused lots of problems because you
know things used to clash to have
clashes in the global namespace it was
hard to manage versions versions would
like not be could simply not be
compatible so module and blurs exist
solve that problem the problem we had
with managing dependencies and they also
helped us with lots of things like web
pack this is a great job were like
bundle splitting which solves the
problem of sending less bytes on the
wire and front-end frameworks well if
you might remember jQuery who here
remembers rate query ok painful times
but it's great to so Front Range firm
works help us separating how we manage
like the like the display like how we
display things and business logic so
frameworks just provide us abstractions
and abstractions they're necessary to
reduce the cognitive load or how things
work so that you can focus on what
matters so that you can focus on
creating and all of that how like
happened because
the web platform moves too fast and if
we had to have standards for everything
well we would be in a very hard place
right because making a standard takes
time you know it takes lots of drafts
that you need to have like multiple
people giving their opinion and
everything so if actually allowed the
community should come up with solutions
you have natural selection so packages
that solve problems
well people start adopting people start
contributing they get bigger we have
more material more documentation on them
and that helps us putting the power into
the hands of communities and makes it
easier for us to have tools that
actually source problem solve our
problems from modern up header them
having someone tell us what should fix
our problems and also if you take a look
at the JavaScript environment you see
that lots of packages like they have
kind of this UNIX philosophy in there
like they do one thing in to do what
they do it well so for example in
JavaScript
rather than just having like j-unit
which does everything so you have mocha
and you have choice well mocha just runs
tests and chai just as assertions and if
you want to replace one of the pieces in
this stack you can just do it because we
also work writers that work together and
also because so much complexity in
software comes from trying to make one
thing do two things
as I've said we write programs that work
together so it's easier to increase the
stack of technology we use and if you
stop and think about you see that all
these tools we have they're not new you
know like all of them had alternatives
like before any km p.m. we had rubbish
ends we have pie pie we had many other
things you know JSX mixing markup with
javascript we had in forex a long time
ago Babel you know compiler principles
have been around things I don't know
forever maybe goop grant NPM scripts all
of that I already had that wrong 64
thing and it was called new make and new
makes two serves lots of problems like
we use know making chai and I know lots
of people that's you use new make
nowadays and you saw because they're
really hipsters now because they want to
you know like use this school choose
because it's sauce problem submit
solvers it solves it well rec native
well using web technologies to develop
for mobile we already had that with
whe I hope none of you had to use that
so how can we deal with this but the
first thing to realize is that obviously
you don't need to know everything so if
you actually stop and realize that
you're going solving problems now
writing code or using cool national
technology you see that you should you
can just like learn things as you go
like learn things as they start solving
your problems and not not be afraid
because every developer you know got
there by solving problems they were
unqualified to serve and today actually
do that and when you go learn I think
people should learn from the beginning
you will learn computer science
fundamentals and JavaScript learn CSS
before you know like learning like react
and all that stuff but sometimes you
know it's kinda hard to learn how to
swim by studying dynamic of fluids so
now you just got to jump into the pool
and try it yourself and also it's
important you don't be too attached to
single technology and to not be defined
by your stack you know if you're a great
engineer if you know how to solve
problems well you'd be welcome in places
the right a great variety of languages
like I know for example like Rob bike
like he's very well known for go for
example but I'm sure like every company
in the world would like to have Rob
bikers in each near and I have a tail
here to illustrate this which is called
master foo and the recruiter so if you
can please dim the lights that'll be
very cool
can we either if this is yes or no but
I'll just keep going okay nice
so a technical recruiter having
discovered that the ways of UNIX hackers
were strange to him sought an audience
with master foo to learn more about the
way the recruiter said I have observed
the UNIX hackers skull or become annoyed
when I ask them how many years of
experience they have in a new
programming language why is this sir
master food stood and began to pace
across the office for the recruiter was
puzzled and asked what are you doing
learning how to
we bite lots of food I saw you walk
through the door that we could exclaimed
and you're obviously not stumbling over
your own feet obviously you already know
how to walk yes but this floor is new to
me replied mastership
upon hearing this the recruiter was
enlightened I hope you weren't lighting
too so if you can turn lights on again
they'll be nice thank you
so an hour great advice is to do things
that don't scale and this applies not
only to code but also to businesses you
know like try hypothesis make sure that
the code you write your writing should
be like should be written so this comes
from a blog post by program in which he
explains how Airbnb founders got there
by actually like going to places
themselves and taking photographs
themselves and you're doing all these
black manual stuff to make sure that
what they're doing most valuable and
they were actually solving a problem so
focus on what matters
aka don't do back shedding and if we
have time for questions yet please ask
me why where the bike shedding comes
from and I think the whole point of this
whole talk is to tell people to not get
ahead of themselves right so apply GDG
approach take small steps gradual steps
towards a solution so that you can
reduce the scope of your decisions and
make better decisions and well rather
than just like following tutorials were
just like reading about things try to
view things because like most of the
times in tutorials what people do is
they create problems so that they can
show you certain abstractions but then
like it becomes hard for you to decide
when you need a certain abstraction and
abstractions they have a coast and you
must learn that goes so first you learn
the value of abstraction then you learn
the cost of abstraction and only then
you're ready to engineer and also
something I think it's it's a bit wrong
is calling ourselves engineers I don't
think there's a very accurate term
because you know like some like some
buildings have been there for a long
time and they never collapse Wells
implications crash all the time right
software like software is it likes a new
thing
it's something we you only do for like I
dunno 70 years or something and I have a
good analogy which comes from some
Newman's book about micro-services which
refers to what we should call ourselves
so this is Barcelona and this is
Barcelona seen from Sky
so you notice a huge difference between
those two pictures right so when you're
building software I think you should do
as people that plan Barcelona I did so
you cannot like predict how the city is
going to look like in one or two hundred
years or three hundred years right it
just grows organically people move from
place to place and then necessities they
have changed just like the necessities
you have with your software change so
rather than just like being an engineer
I think we should do more of what's like
real iterative development we should
instead be town planners especially
because software is flexible and
engineering is not in our view time is
compile time I spend more time designing
and thinking the building we can break
things all the time we can always change
things and it's a lot easier to change
things because why we work with you
thought we don't work with physical
matter and we can beaut as many times as
one who can test things a lot easier
than people that actually do civil
engineering so be a town planner let
your software grow adapt as needed to
proper if iterative development and well
abstract abstractions only work well
when you have the right context for them
and the right context we won't develop
as the system develops other advice I
have for you is an advice I got from a
friend in college and I think it's great
advice which is to strive to be lazy so
whenever you're doing something and it
feels like too much work well then
that's the time when you should like
look forward to finding a better
solution to your problem but sometimes
you not realize you're having too much
work to do something which is why it's
so important to come to conferences like
this and talk to people and see what
they're doing and learn how you can
improve your own workflow and you know
be better at solving problems but I
think it all boils down to being curious
so I think this great code from our
smart sums it up so I think that people
should be curious read widely try new
things
because what people call intelligence in
the end it just boils down to curiosity
but if I had just summed this all up I
think in a single advice it would be to
solve problems you know like code is not
this this thing we do just because we
like it like we offer go to the world
and we should actually make it just
something for people so focus on solving
problems thank you very much and here I
have a few references and great blog
posts which I think would be very
valuable mostly about like how to
approach requirements how to approach
design and career in general so I think
that's it thank you very much I think we
have time for questions right because I
always speak faster when I thank you
anyone comments questions okay we got
one very nice
how many burning projects I have been
well it depends on what you'd call a
burning project how would you define a
burning project so one thing like one so
so what he said is that deep one in a
project where people focus on so in
choosing technologies rather than
solving problems so I think one is it
will not affect project but what what
example of what people do commonly is
like when you when you go try to like
bootstrap like rate of react application
first time like you're not focusing on
what it should do and then you spend all
this time like fine-tuning or label and
wipe a configuration rather than just
getting it to work and adding things as
you need them like you try to predict
what you're going to do and also like
one thing I see a common misconception I
see about GDG for example which is very
related to this is that when people
think about unity do they just think oh
I'm going to write this like huge test
and like I'm going to write all these
fast and then I'm gonna write the
culprit it's not what you need ease
about so rather than just like writing
loads of tests at once like write a very
simple test make a code pass instead of
just like trying to get it all done at
once like trying to meet all the
requirements at once so I think those
are trees and poles where I see that
happening
and I think that also sometimes people
want to use fancy tools for lots of
things like so there's this whole thing
now about like intimate energy making so
when people like try to beautiful
software themselves like try to build
programs themselves and many people in
the energy making community they don't
know how to code and they learn it as
they go so in their first prototype to
make sure that they need that that
that's going to solve a problem they
start with like I don't know like an
Excel spreadsheet a type form or
something like that and once they see
that's needed they then go and develop
it so I think those are some examples
anyone else cool thank you learn it by
here
cool thank you very much